films and photographs are what
introduced us to the famous earthworks
of the American Southwest having
produced the sights auras their
documentation inspired us to make the
pilgrimage but they also produced
expectations that were confounded by
experience often on our journey we found
photographs to be forbidden or futile
what do film and photography leave out
smell scale our own feelings at the site
the histories of expropriation buried
under the surface these things seem to
be beyond our documentary grasp what we
offer then is a travel log of the
undocumented
the sheer flatness of the Great Salt
Lake that greeted us from the plane
utterly flat deadly flat was sensory
deprivation pure flat then white then
pink at the edge and Bryan almost
imagined
the receding pink water of the Great
Salt Lake made the jetty look a little
forgotten long cracks in the soil made
this forgotten feeling even stronger
some three or four dead pelicans around
the site appeared crystallized in time
the scorching dry air kept things from
rotting I could see some salt crystals
underneath one of the dead Birds the
death looks so undisturbed here like the
site itself
from the Spiral Jetty to the sun tunnels
it was 116 miles of nothing
repetitive stretches of brown and green
my mother would have called its credit
dear Albanian for this great expanse
wasteland a big nothing
we traveled so many miles while seeing
so little we spent more time in the
vastness between sites than in the sites
themselves as we arrived to the Sun
tunnels the bus LED and air in sand we
wanted to see the work before the sky
turned dark and we arrived just before
the sunset there Peter taught us that if
you just hold your fist out toward the
Sun you can measure how much time you
have before it sets one fist from the
horizon to the Sun gives you about one
hour
driving to double negative
I kept envisioning a particular image a
photograph of an artist I worked for
taken two decades earlier
moments after he ignited a handheld
explosive forming a small mushroom cloud
in the air he used the iconic view of
double negative the two subtractions
aligned with the curving Mesa and with
his cloud he made the work his own I
decided to do the same Ryanair agreed to
take the photograph though this was the
only thing that went my way I was
without a stockpile of firecrackers and
gunpowder forced to improvise I decided
to set a small fire though I had flipped
through pages and pages of archival
photographs documenting the mini trials
of this project nothing prepared me for
the wind I had never thought of double-
as a place but rather always as an image
the wind put out the fires I tried to
light indifferent to my ambition and
will by the time I stood at the exact
spot where my boss had created the image
the sky had turned cloudy and purple the
wind was so strong I was afraid that I
would blow into the void
to document the universe one must invent
a representation of infinity and in turn
failed to represent its true enormity it
is impossible to directly capture the
Very Large Array much as VLA zone
attempt to visualize the universe is
merely a highly mediated translation of
radio signals into images throughout the
trip we often felt that the vastness of
the landscape swallowed the projects of
man but the array was an exception it
dominated the landscape
it's not as if we could have captured
the missile-launch we accidentally
witnessed when we visited White Sands
Missile Range it happened too quickly it
was too awesome nor the somber weight of
trendy side or the first nuclear weapon
was detonated anyway no photographs were
allowed the activity there was
confidential and governmental there was
one exception though the Oryx an
antelope species native to Africa but
imported to New Mexico to increase game
tourism they now thrive in white sands a
landscape characterized by desolation
and destruction the Oryx is punctuated
moments of mourning moments of the
technological sublime in moments of
trepidation as our bodies encountered
remnants of a nuclear explosion
upon arrival of Acoma Pueblo we were
told by our guide that videos were
prohibited and photos were to be taken
only unauthorized devices an
understandable practice given the
community's historical tendency towards
secrecy in the service of
self-preservation we were surprised
though when Reiner having just pulled
out a pen and notebook was informed that
writing too was forbidden sitting with
this rule I felt a strange splitting of
the senses my attention drawn to but the
weight of language and knowing and the
frailty of the image I hadn't realized
that Lightning field encompassed such a
vast area four hundred stainless steel
poles measuring one mile by one
kilometer the poles could only be seen
frontally from the horizontal but what
did lightning field look like from above
did it's razor sharp points recede into
the air at a certain height render the
silvery grid invisible imagine a
nocturnal flash and then for an instant
all of it illuminated in plain sight the
occasional Blackfoot Daisy bloomed in
front of de Maria's techno sculptures
hairs and Jackrabbits nibbled from low
shrubs leaping with sprigs in their
mouths photo energy the catalyst which
transforms sunlight into sugar is the
same element which allows lightning
field to be captured on film a treat
we crossed state after state time zone
after time zone and nudged right up into
the us-mexico border before we finally
made it to Marfa we befriended strangers
at Prada Marfa as we took turns
photographing one another it's only so
isolated
apparently we waited ten minutes in the
dark before the Flavin piece was turned
on then suddenly we were transported to
a thicken world breathing peer magenta
and forest green we were asked not to
take photos so as to encourage us to be
present to keep the tour moving and so
we fought the magnetic attraction of our
hands to the camera phones in our
pockets but the impulse proved too
strong we couldn't resist making a few
the block a portion of Donald Judd's
sixty thousand three hundred forty acres
of Texan land full of countless
meticulously arranged objects we were
constantly reminded of this as we
strolled through beautifully staged
rooms that served as the backdrop to
Donald Judd's life though its scale and
obsessive noeleen may suggest otherwise
the space is intimate subtle
misalignments of the objects are
evocative of this potential for life for
entropy the tools helped us imagine what
dad used to do here how he used to live
here
no photographs allowed such declaratives
and demands reminded us that this place
was once meant for life in a sense the
undocumented all converge with the over
documented we could take the memory of
these objects and sites home but nothing
else
medium dimension author these specific
details would be published in the
catalog resume responsible for telling
the definitive narrative of jud efforts
to create definitive narratives through
controlled representation and judgy and
meticulousness reparent and several of
the sites we visited well the government
authored a particular narrative of white
sands de maria so rigidly controlled the
representation of his lightning field
but these falsely singular eyes
narratives became confounded in the
spaces between the official
representations and dark experience
prior to our trip images defined our
knowledge of these sites selected images
controlled the reception meaning and
representation of these works but on
site we were unable to deny their
material spatial significance the
uncontestable eyes Dobb jecht swallowed
by the messy and complicated histories
and landscapes which were so easily
pushed to the background in editorials
and artist statements here it was plain
to see that the efforts control
reception meaning and representation
were futile
you